[Musique]
mesdames messieurs bonsoir bonsoir
christine arron soir franck bonsoir à
tous enfin nous voilà avec les candidats
donc du marigot en vous demandant
d'accepter de nos plus plates excuses
nous avons eu un problème a redit mardi
soir indépendants de notre volonté nous
n'avons donc pu vous présenter ce débat
avec des quatre candidats du marigot
alors pourquoi le marigot parce que à
l'exception du carbet il y a quelques
années cette configuration politique est
très rare en martinique y voir même dans
l'hexagone un ancien maire battu aux
précédentes élections qui tente de
retrouver son siège
ce soir donc nous avons quatre candidats
qui étaient déjà tous présents en 2014
et que nous vous présentons suivant
l'ordre désigné par le tirage au sort
alors monsieur daniel gros désir
bonsoir bonsoir à vous vous êtes vous
avez 61 ans vous êtes agent de la banque
postale le nom de votre liste c'est
ensemble bâtissons d'autres à venir vous
étiez adjoint au maire des mules en 2014
pendant quelques mois
monsieur patrick bredas bonsoir bonsoir
bonsoir aux téléspectateurs de
martinique 1ère vous allez entendu au
margutti ma routine qui nous écoutent
alors vous avez 54 ans tout à fait vous
êtes agent territorial à la ctm votre
liste appel l'alliance nouvelle c'est
votre deuxième candidature tout à fait
joseph peraste bonsoir bonsoir madame
vous avez 69 ans vous êtes professeur
retraité vous êtes le maire sortant tête
de liste pour un marigot fort et
solidaire vous êtes également
vice-président le cap nord et membre
fondateur du parti régionaliste
martiniquais ange lavenaire bonsoir vous
avez 73 ans vous êtes professeur
retraité tête de liste union pour la
promotion et l'animation du marigot
conseiller municipal d'opposition vous
avez est également conseiller général de
1998 à 2000 15 président de la
communauté des communes du nord de la
martinique de 95 à 2014
et puis bien sûr président fondateur de
cap nord martinique c'était en 2014
découvrons à présent la ville du marigot
aux chiffres alors le marigot c'est
de 3300 habitants une population en
déclin jusqu'à l'egypte a salué les
maskoutains
[Rires]
c'est un électorat c'est l'énergie denis
merville à l'énergie l'eau faut bien les
possibilités et leur dire que l'espèce
débat va leur permettre une fois pour
toutes deux cas le fil des choses on y
arrive on y arrive on va d'abord
présenté la ville christine oui alors
comme je vous le disais le marigot c'est
près de 3300 habitants une population en
déclin le taux de chômage lui s'établit
à 18% alors l'activité économique est
tournée essentiellement vers
l'agriculture le commerce et les
services
la pêche reste minoritaire au marigot 1
puisque le nombre de professionnels de
la mer est très faible
ils sont moins de 5 les autres
proviennent des communes avoisinantes
alors la ville du marigot elle n'a pas
de dettes
celle ci a été intégralement remboursées
c'était en novembre 2019 pour un emprunt
de 500 mille euros contractée en
novembre 2005 et tout de suite notre
traditionnel micro trottoir qui nous le
savons fait beaucoup parler dans les
communes que pensent ses habitants du
marigot de leur ville
on regarde si tout de suite mais nos
toutes les communes ou des choses et il
faudrait changer certaines choses mais
oui vous avez changé je vais pas vous
dire qu'est ce que vous a changé mais
pas si vous devez changer beaucoup de
chiens qui se balade sans rien à iso
part de travail or hier et chômage des
jeunes
oui chômage des jeunes il marque
beaucoup de taxi
par ici au marigot rançon beaucoup
appris de ce taxi pour aller ou à
fort-de-france ou de transport de
voitures c'est difficile oui ah oui ah
oui c'est pas c'est pas sans peine
bienvenue au marigot je suis là je suis
toujours chez moi y aviez il faut faire
des activités pour les enfants tous ces
gardiens il n'y a pas en mal
y a pas de batterie il n'y a pas de
football les bâches m&a pas ça il ya
beaucoup de choses à faire et waddan le
marché là et où jade ou à danser je ne
peux pas aller danser et je viens danser
au bal de la mjc avant de partir j'étais
inscrit la mjc ont dansé ya beaucoup de
choses mais maintenant la plus où il est
au malg au marigot pour moi c'est mort
il a réglé les dettes qui avait laissé
son prédécesseur mais maintenant il a
des choses à faire notamment cible
d'abord nisé hégémonie il ya un stade
prévu à la pointe des logements sociaux
j alors je pense que il faut au moins
deux mandats engagez-vous pouvoir
les gens réclament ses murs c'est normal
d'être en retour ils sont très partagés
ou bien c'est 50-50 bien bon je dis ça
voilà messieurs
alors vos réactions d'abord monsieur
gros désir
ensuite monsieur peraste ensuite
monsieur bré d'assez ensuite monsieur
l'avenir monsieur vos désirs alors juste
avant vous permettez moi de pas de
penser à deux sociétés de la société et
une personne en particulier
ce sont les analyses de fond santini je
pense que ce sont des gens qui vivent un
moment difficile en sont actuellement
et en plus c'est la démocratie qui en
prend un coup quand un journal disparaît
et je pense que pour la matinée que ce
n'est pas une bonne chose j'espère qu'on
va trouver une situation meilleure pour
pour eux et puis l'autre que ce sont nos
amis qui sont en lutte sociale qui
douteraient longtemps et qui cause
beaucoup de dégâts et que j'espère que
là aussi il va avoir une solution pour
le micro trottoir soit dire à personne
qui handicape à granby qui a pas de
basket qui après yann balaya basket
football n'y a pas d'infrastructures et
c'est ça le problème ça le gros problème
de margaux depuis plus d'une vingtaine
d'années qu'il y ait pas d face tutu
pour pouvoir accueillir les gens qui
font leur activité et que c'est vrai que
la situation n'est pas très habile
messieurs bredas ben oui c'est mon tour
ben oui d'accord merci bouge nous parle
du premier tirage au sort
la coque et papou la conclusion annoncée
par la coque comme on a eu 2 tirages
mais tout va bien alors tout et je
voulais déjà au salué les mains ligotées
ni les margoulins qui nous écoutent et
dieu que à travers ce micro trottoir que
nous avons
ça reflète bien ce qu'il se passe à
margaux maintenant je vais pas me mettre
à la place des marais gaudin ils sont là
ils vivent à marigot et moi j'ai ce
plaisir de résider à marigot ce sont les
mêmes choses que nous voyons maintenant
monsieur gougnan constate que ea du
handball il ya du foot à margaux moi je
vis à margaux je regarde effectivement
il ya quelques personnes qui se
débattent pour tenter de maintenir le
sport à margaux mais dans les promesses
de monsieur perez était avant toute
chose où m ce stade aux normes et dans
les six mois premier échec pour cette
équipe je rappelle à monsieur vos désirs
il a été président de la commission vie
associative jusqu'au mois de juillet
2019 et que ça nous a coûté quand même
son poste 42 1992 euros
quand même pour mener à bien cette
mission ça c'est nos impôts et avec la
complicité de monsieur perez qui lui a
permis de rester au conseil municipal et
toucher des indemnités à hauteur de 40
de 1992 euros tout en sachant monsieur
piras le savez que monsieur dream était
déjà un opposant dès le départ de cette
mandature va on va maintenant on va
revenir sur la tête associés juste sur
balles à traction le mégot j'ai vu des
gens s'exprimer c'est vrai on attend
beaucoup de choses pour la prochaine
mandature
sans trop de promesses avec des
propositions c'est un nom c'est ce que
nous nous essaierons à l'alliance
nouvelle de faire de proposer pour
exemple ces jeunes n'ont pas de stade un
plateau sportif
on dit bien un plateau sportif avec une
montée des équipements et bien entendu
pour gérer tout ça un financement
pluriannuel ça je les dis et je répète
tout le temps toujours la même chose
concernant le transport voyez bien sûr
un problème récurrent j'ai eu l'occasion
dans d'autres débats de m'exprimer sur
ce sujet et d'ailleurs personne ici ne
peut le contredire
c'est un véritable problème et je parle
surtout du problème et erp urbain ça
veut dire que les gens qui sont à ma
hugo en carottier ont d'énormes
difficultés à se déplacer et plus
particulièrement nos seniors d'ailleurs
monsieur perez qui aimait et qui est à
quatre noms c'est là que je dis je
comprends pas de caussade et manche
avait une possibilité peut-être pour
soulager ne serait-ce que momentanément
ses maris gauthey lors des
manifestations il existe maintenant vous
me démentirait monsieur peyras de
véhicules mises à disposition pour les
communes qui le souhaitent lors de
manifestations
pourquoi vous n'avez jamais pensé ne
serait ce qu'un petit soulagement
donc je vais prendre le temps d'informer
après ces six ce que je dis n'est pas
vrai vous le dites ans j'ai pris le
temps de me former
j'ai dit que monsieur perez pareil pour
ce transport
et ça c'est mon cheval de bataille nous
n'avons qu'à deux transporteurs à
margaux qui se bat comme ils le peuvent
ils on réclame un petit panneau je vous
dit à monsieur perez depuis l'entrée en
fonctions de monsieur perez
ce fan ou et en commande voyez
simplement pour permettre au taximan qui
sont sur place de délimiter cet espace
ils me l'ont dit de poser la question à
monsieur perez ou est ce panneau alors
merci le pirate s'est ensuite monsieur
de lavenère sur les micro trottoirs
oui bien sûr vous pouvez toujours
répondre d'abord nouveaux trottoirs et
ensuite vous allez d'ailleurs d'abord
bonjour aux amis du marigot bonjour à
tous les mailles butin à tous les
martiniquais
je voudrais simplement dire concernant
donc ce micro-trottoir oui j'ai entendu
et je remercie d'ailleurs toutes ces
personnes d'avoir pu s'exprimer et de
dire ce qu'il pense ou encore ce qu'ils
vivent et ils ont raison
le maire devra en tirer des conclusions
concernant le transport la petite dame
qui s'est exprimé sur cet aspect je lui
dirai attention de ne pas se faire avoir
par les candidats dans la mesure où j'ai
le document devant moi le transport
c'est l'organisation
le responsable de l'organisation du
transport à la martinique c'est la ctn
et en date du jeudi 30 janvier 2020
tous les maires du nord atlantique ont
été convoqués par monsieur le président
alfred marie jeanne pour signer la
convention de compensation et
d'obligation de service public entre
martini transport et six coopératives
qui ont été payées dans le nord
atlantique pour l'organisation du
transport
j'ai donc ici tout ce qui concerne cette
organisation
monsieur le président de la ctm nous a
invités nous les maires pour l'afflux
effectivement nous et voilà c'est passé
à la télé et tout donc aujourd'hui je le
dis clairement il faut qu'on arrête de
dire n'importe quoi parce qu'on est en
campagne
je crois que il y a lieu de rétablir une
certaine vérité concernant
interquartiers car il a des interurbains
il s'est encore trompé un interquartiers
interquartiers nous avons deux ou trois
taxis sur le territoire de la ville
je crois savoir que ça se passe assez
bien c'est vrai qu'il peut avoir un
petit temps d'attentes assez long ça
dépend s'ils vont déjeuner ou s'ils vont
prendre le petit déj
mais enfin l'organisation permet un bon
fonctionnement quand monsieur bride à
ses voc le dossier cap nord là encore
cela demande de l'attention
si on veut être justement défenseur des
professions libérales endroit réfléchir
et bien oui cap nord a mis à disposition
de certaines villes saintes maries
marigot et laurens que deux bus de
minibus et donc chaque collectivité
chaque maire devra attendre son tour
mais nous devons aussi réfléchir sur ce
fait dans la mesure où est bien parce
que c'est du transport gratuit pour une
catégorie de personnes
il faut savoir que nous assistons là
aussi sous l'économie parce que les deux
transporteurs agréés et qui ont leurs
dettes et bien le maire lui-même va se
porter comme un concurrent puisque il ya
une concurrence au niveau du transport
puisque les gens pourront préférer
prendre celui qui est gratuit et le pain
payer donc il ya de la réflexion à mener
et quand un maire est élu par le peuple
en 2014 vous développez la commune je
crois qu'il y à des réflexions
importantes à mener
à ce niveau c'est très important puis je
voudrais terminer vous que pat hibulaire
s'arrête un peu cette désinformation car
souvent ils brandissent ce document il
s'agit de joseph peyras quand il avait
fait sa profession de foi en 2014
monsieur partie nous avons le même
rassure-toi présente le jeu présente le
mien nous avons le même le même document
monsieur partie le bidasse dit que
j'avais 52 projets ou même promesse je
vais définir tout à leurs promesses et
projet 52 projets nous avons un document
et cela me peine de le dire devant 2
devant les médias sans peine sincèrement
vêtir projet parce que vous savez devant
chaque projet il y à un astérix 21
projets mais la confusion vient à ce
niveau c'est à dire que vous avez des
projets dans leur intitulé qui prennent
deux lignes ou trois les et je dirais
donc mon document ne comporte que 53
lits confie-t-il ligne et projets that
is the question
alors monsieur la mer oui alors
évidemment je me réjouis d'avoir écouté
des espaces du coup trottoir mais parmi
toutes les communes séparées la même
chose trois domaines essentiels sont
évoqués le premier domaine s'il volait
de la jeunesse et de l'emploi
elle promet de l'animation de la ville
problème du transport
si le transport c'est la collectivité
territoriale qui s'en occupe 6 à sa
compétence par manque de transport et
puis nous avons l'animation de la ville
évidemment c'est inventer des choses
aujourd'hui vous permettre c'est vrai
que les fastueux à 7 mario sont ne font
pas légion
et pour cause c'est que toutes les
institutions sont vieilles et que par
conséquent il faut les reprendre
alors c'est pas depuis 20 ans on en a
pas on en a depuis 2011
parce que le terrain mais n'est-ce pas
été endommagé et de plus en plus c'est
l'otan
s'agissait de l'emploi je rappelle
toujours gens que les villes recrute des
personnes ont accompagné de pôle emploi
avec des contrats qui sont à durée
déterminée que par conséquent avec la
formation qualifiante annoncé pour
chacune de ces personnes sinon je
rejette l'idée qui est de l'est par un
des niveaux des victoires de dire qu'il
faut donner au maire une chance pourquoi
un deuxième mandat faut pas donner aux
maires de l'est et madame on va dire
pauvre vous avez terminé sur une photo
alors passion justement la première
thématique de ce débat finances et
emploi alors au cours de ces cinq
dernières années la ville du marigot a
réussi à apurer la totalité de sa dette
on l'a vu soit la somme de deux cent
quatorze mille deux cents 84 euros
messieurs les candidats que pensez vous
de cette situation qui a consisté en
priorité à résorber la dette de la ville
on commence avec vous monsieur gros
désir
oui juste quand même revenir en arrière
sur soi de transport ce que donc
effectivement monsieur père a tout à
fait raison et qu'on allait évoquer
effectivement la laïcité m a pris ses
responsabilités pour faire un petit peu
ce qui a été fait au nord caraïbe et que
mes matinées de transport ne date que
depuis deux ou trois ans pas plus
donc le problème de transport malgré ça
fait ça fait un bon moment qu'on a ce
problème de transport malgré qu'on a
toujours évoqué et les mères avaient la
possibilité de mettre en place autre
chose il savait très très longtemps
ceci dit j'aurais aimé que j'apprends
que la dtn a apuré de simples 2018 et
240000 euros qui avaient qu'il y avait
un endettement donc vous m'apprenez
parce que vous avez des chiffres de
résolument déjà vérifié conviennent de
l'officiel et qui viennent des services
municipaux comme nous remercions
d'ailleurs qui ont fêté les chances a
servi que nous aurions dû avoir parce
que le
des comptes administratifs 2010 n'est
pas encore senti que je sache donc vous
annoncer mais il faut avoir quand même
pas qu'on en a pas mais sais tu ce
serait une bonne chose que la déçoit et
puis quoi que c'était pas une dette qui
qui était forcément lourde pour la
commune parce que d'autant plus que ça
faisait ce qu'il restait 6 faisait un an
un an de 16 mois exactement durée
d'endettement qu'on pouvait et éponger
donc que c'était d'être remboursés à
hauteur de 39 milles euros pas an par
année donc les pouilles
bon tant mieux si la ville a tout et
purée de d'un court mais c'était pas une
bête qui qui empêchait à la ville de
fonctionner monsieur bré d'as alors
comment à son habitude monsieur p
grassement seaway qu'il est un pédagogue
mais j'attends le 15 mars au soir pour
qu'ils expliquent c'est comme du ligne
et 52 projets moir je m'arrête
volontairement que respectueusement à 52
projets parce que je suis partout à
marigot c'est quelque chose que
j'affectionne particulièrement ce que
détestent monsieur perez la proximité et
je ne veux pas rajouter les au projet
qui là encore poules et poulets
margotton et qui ne verront jamais le
jour
maintenant pareil et l'essai de nier la
sa responsabilité quand je parle de
soulager les margoulins que ces
véhicules existe à cap nord mais il
n'avait jamais paru moi je mets faut je
veux bien entendre que la commune a
n'est pratiquement plus endettés d'après
ce que vous avez des deux il y avait une
dette depuis 2005 et cette dette a été
au mieux pour les marigots temps je
dirais mais comme le dit monsieur gaudin
yeux qui est là et qui siège au concept
mans qu'il n'y ait plus parce qu'il a
fait le choix depuis deux mois de ne
plus y être mais monsieur là venez un
ancien maire vous du a sans doute
quelque chose concernant ce
désendettement de la ville
en tout cas quand les mâles gotein jolie
rencontre ils n'ont ils n'ont pas
bénéficié je donne deux trois exemples
si on a pu épuré cette dette
je veux bien savoir où sont passés je le
demande à monsieur peyras les 150000
euros que vous avez eu deux
la ctm pour la réparation de la chapelle
le renforcement du talus de la chapelle
150000 euros
monsieur perez a tout récupéré appuyer
cette dette je veux bien de quoi jadu où
sont passés les subventions aux
associations c'est peut-être à ce prix
là qu'on a été sacrifié ma super à
savoir si durant sa mandature 928 1058
pour effectuer des opérations sous les
équipements de la commune pour tout ce
qui est lié à la petite enfance et gsea
les documents parce que monsieur peyras
je prends toujours beaucoup de
précautions quand je dis quelque chose
je prends le temps de me former dans le
cadre de sa politique d' aide aux
communes les collectivités on va
accorder une subvention d'autorisation
de programme de 927 1000 s'intitule 108
euros 80 14 au marigot pour la
réalisation de six opérations et ces
opérations se décline de la façon
suivante aménageant aménagement du
plateau sportif au stade municipal dont
on ne verra jamais la couleur
et ça sera à nous de le faire si les
mailles boutin accepte que nous prenons
la gestion de cette commune
le réaménagement d'un ancien manche est
et je rappelle aussi à ceux qui vous
l'ont venus en maillots pour voir cette
oeuvre réalisée monsieur perez en
sectionnant en 2e manche et c'est une
oeuvre d'art monsieur wyser déjà six
minutes
tout à fait pardonnez moi parce que
vraiment vous êtes déjà six minutes
monsieur bredas d'accord mais je veux
chiffres oui mais on va revenir sur
cette caisse du grand crohot me merci
vous mais qu'elle a commenté monsieur
l'avenir alors écoutez moi je dois bien
la dette
non mais nous aurons une question
puisque c'est la question sur ses lacets
on a dû déroger aux à l'ordre à cause de
la question
ce sera oui d'abord à vous monsieur
d'oman que pensez vous justement de
cette méthode année a consisté à apurer
la dette j'ai municipal n'est pas une
affaire de petits boulots à la chance il
faut la réflexion canton
c'est ma responsabilité en 2004 nous
avons contacté 500000 euros
n'est ce pas de danse c'était pour faire
changer le parc automobile est également
procédé à des investissements dans la
ville mais pour obtenir ces 5000 euros
il faut être en gestion saine il faut
avoir la capacité et la possibilité
d'obtenir des bas n'espère 1,1 point à
ce que c'est le cas aujourd'hui on
s'interroge
parce qu'en réalité terminer de payer un
tract 9000 euros merci monsieur l'avoir
rappelé après 15 ans et que tu es 15 ans
mais c'est une performance
aujourd'hui la ville de margaux n'est
pas en mesure n'est ce pas d'assumer ses
responsabilités en utilisant les
subventions qui sont déjà à disposition
et le vin lui même a avoué qu'il ne
pourrait pas des dossiers pour la
prochaine mandature
il dit qu'il présence et douchez n'est
ce pas à la fête
oui il faut faire la fête mais pas
mettez vous dans la fête parce que c'est
grave de faire des photos 3d
et puis de l'intégrer dans un
environnement et puis donne un beau
projet stade
et puis on a compté sur l'avenir je
comprends pas trop ce que vous n'êtes
pas ce que vous êtes en train de nous
dire en gros que vous êtes vous avez
quitté la municipalité avec une petite
dette avec une petite dette comme ce
père est arrivent ils à régler cette
mission de moi et qu'il avait cette
dette c'est tout à fait est que derrière
elle ne pourra pas emprunter pour
aujourd'hui mais je ne peux pas mais
pour quelle raison mais écoutez moi je
vois des comptes administratifs je vois
des comptes administratifs et je
soupçonne je soupçonne monsieur père est
très fortement et je le dis très
publiquement et très officiellement de
cacher des dépenses de soin de cacher
des dépenses c'est quand même grave mais
écoutez moi je le dis je souffre je n'ai
pas dit il cache vieux soupçonne un côté
négatif c'est surveillé protégé mais
écoutez moi monsieur dans le crotoy de
l'égalité départ contrôle de régularité
alors maintenant je monsieur gp restent
alors ce choix est plutôt que d'investir
sur les constructions sur un marché sur
une chapelle enfin je ne sais sa
structure ce choix là pourquoi est ce
que vous l'avez fait de rigolade est
d'abord oublié excusez moi je crois que
on a compris quelque chose vous même
vous journalistes vous déclaré ne pas
comprendre les propos des uns et les
autres c'est pas de ma faute je
n'appelle pas l'asie mais ne leur faut
arrêter il faut traiter voudrais pour
commencer avec vos démagogie démagogie
ça va vous aurez par personne et ça vous
effraie la finance je n'interviens pas
tant vous vous exposez donc permettez un
moment c'est difficile monsieur l'avenir
on comprend d'ailleurs l'étonnement a
été dès le début présenter puisque vous
avez été battu en 2014
vous mangez n'est ce pas cette rancoeur
et il vous fallait revenir
je dois préciser aux téléspectateurs que
tous ici
les quatre candidats nous sommes des
politiques depuis un moment puisque tous
ont déjà été candidat mais monsieur ou
au désir a été candidat tête de liste à
un certain moment donc que nous soyons
calme entre nous que nous acceptons de
nous respecter
et puis de dire la vérité aux maintenu
qu'elle avait été tombe aujourd'hui la
ville de margaux n'a pas de dettes
or je me rappelle bien pas bien
longtemps celle à venir au cours d'un
débat télévisé disait que la situation
était catastrophique aux mâles ont même
été plus ou moins bon mais attend de ses
propos aujourd'hui il avalé sa langue il
ne peut pas s'exprimer
je lui dirai simplement et à tous les
deux autres attendons tranquillement le
15 mars
je crois que c'est ça que nous devons
être patients oui mais sa légende
monsieur et das évoqué tout à l'heure
des problèmes de de soutien été versés
et une tribu accepter une chamelle il
est dans le faux ce sont des arrêtés
d'attribution de subventions mais s'est
arrêté d'attribution de subventions
monsieur bouhedda ou temps
vous avez été adjoint au maire pendant
13 ans si vous avez été sanctionné en
2014 c'est un peu pour cela quand on
reçoit s'est arrêtée de subventions
c'est pas de l'argentin il faut qu'il y
ait l'apport de la commune puisqu'il ya
des montages et chaque collectivité
intervient à hauteur d'1 d'un certain
pourcentage
donc il faut qu'il y ait la part
communale donc la ctm le roi tous ces
organismes peuvent être accordées toutes
sortes de subventions mais tant que la
commune n'a pas ces 5 % d'apport bien
les projets n'avancent pas donc toutes
ces subventions s'est arrêté sans bla
mais sur glace oui mais vous vous
trompez un niveau vous vous dites que
nous avons l'argent au malg non ce sont
des actes des subventions qui ont été
sollicités par le maire par les services
de la mairie
mais le dossier sont signés monter que
nous obtenons satisfaction
par contre il faut que nous ayons cet
apport et cet apport excusez moi nous
les aurons à partir de maintenant dans
la mesure où avec la sève l'afd agence
française de développement
nous avons donc des accords des
entretiens qui se déroulent puisque nous
savions que en fin 2019
la dette de la commune serait plus et
donc nous avons entamé maintenant des
procédures et tous nos projets monsieur
wade à ce monsieur ou des yeux qui le
sait et ne se lavent nerfs tous nos
projets seront maintenant en phase de
pouvoir démarrer
je vous remercie alors justement passons
à l'autre à la deuxième question
consacré à cette thématique attend
d'être sacré aux finances et à l'emploi
alors on a dit tout à l'heure un la
ville du marigot compte près de 18 % de
personnes sans emploi c'est donc près
d'un actif sur cinq
les inactifs sont bien plus nombreux
plus d'une trempe plus de 30%
il semblerait en fait que la moitié des
actifs du marigot n'est pas d'activité
franck c'est exactement ça alors qu'est
ce que vous prévoyez messieurs pour
relancer l'emploi pour relancer
l'activité puisque les dettes il ya plus
de dettes au maillot
alors messieurs gros désir même si les
yeux oui donc d'avoir épuré la dette
c'est pas c'est pas le signe d'une bonne
gestion c'est même une erreur parce que
quand on dit que
manipuler la dette et qu'on a parce
qu'on a pas de départ c'est un problème
pourquoi pourquoi avoir et pour hind est
alors alors que tout le monde sait et
monsieur place l'a rappelé que pour
faire des projets il n'y a pas de départ
donc les jeudis et je rappelle aux
téléspectateurs que la le revêtement de
la commune étaient remboursés
régulièrement à hauteur de 39 milles
euros par an et qui restaient et un an
et demi on est d'accord on sait pas donc
ce n'était pas la peine est aujourd'hui
est-ce qu'il faut plus grands attendait
puisqu'il faut quand même donné cette
précision ne se perd à ce vous à dire
que nous on n'est pas dans le vrai donc
et que nous avons nous avons reçu par
exemple des deux de l'argent de la cité
elles n'ont pas là si tu aimes la région
à l'époque et que nous avons fait un
reversement à la région pour ne pas
parce qu'on n'avait pas les pentes pour
pouvoir faire les travaux et c'est ça le
problème quand vous avez pas dépendre
pour faire les travaux
au lieu de faire votre part vous réglez
un montant l'on va solder une dette
alors que c'était pas ça la priorité
c'est ce que me demande qu'est ce qu'il
faut faire pour le margot au niveau
financier relancer l'emploi voilà c'est
là pour relancer l'emploi devrait il ya
pas que le marigot seulement pour
pouvoir il faut quand même qu'il y ait
la cause anti au niveau haut niveau et
départementales mais il faut crier
l'attractivité et l'attractivité
économique c'est de faire appel aux
plans qu'ils existent et nous avons au
niveau de l'état depuis le 1er janvier
2019 la possibilité d'installer la zone
franche d'activité pour propos le mcg
ont donc faire cette demande qui
permettrait à des
des personnes voulant créer des
activités de bénéficier largement de de
l'exonération d'impôts et pour peut-être
par ce biais là pour commencer pour que
les gens puissent trouver de l'emploi au
marigot
il s'agit de sa permettre des gens de
trouver de l'emploi présent une pratique
mois pour relancer la pêche
oui il ya que toulouse avait un super à
port de pêche pour je prends beaucoup
misé ya les uns et oui c'est vrai est ce
que vous allez faire chez pas pour
proposer aux gens à tirer on est par
exemple la jeunesse qu'elle se tourne
vers la pêche mais c'est exactement la
même chose c'est à dire que si elle a
les pêcheurs ce sont des artisans
donc il faut que hill et bénéficie de
certaines exonérations pour pouvoir et
s'installer et c'est ce que le problème
c'est qu'ils ont besoin de paix le wali
long des dépenses donc et s'ils n'ont
pas de ses facilités à ses bénéfices
d'impôt pour pouvoir s'installer ce sera
difficile et si cette attractivité là
qu'il faut mettre comme arrigo il ya les
pêcheurs il ya des agriculteurs aussi
qui en a qu'un qui en ont besoin de ce
magot c'est une terre agricole qu'un
donc on a beau et puis on allait les
services de proximité gergy ça la
percevez vous reposez la même question
monsieur est ce que ça veut dire que
vous vous seriez allé dans dans les
campagnes pour les chercher le redire
vont aller vous allez toi tu vas l'école
de pêche à trinité toi je sais que c'est
quoi votre vos solutions parce que là
vous nous parler d'eux mais pratiquement
les solutions ça serait quoi allécher
rimmel et marie cottin qui sont
peut-être surtout afin de soutenir les
efforts mais il faut il faut qu'ils
aient beaucoup de forums pour pouvoir
déformer sous des choses qui existent de
ce qui existe dans la possibilité de
pouvoir faire
les investissements des emplois à aller
s'inscrire à cette année doit faire des
formations et surtout ça qu'il manque
aussi des formations et qu' ils n'ont
pas d'informations sur place donc créer
des forums créer des espaces pour que
puisse se former que monsieur bredas
vous comment vous envisageriez là la
solution au chômage notamment des jeunes
au marigot
alors je pense que j'ai un certain
nombre de signaux à marigot cancer dans
cette possibilité mais si vous le
permettez vous de bien répondre à
monsieur peraste quand il dit qu'il m'a
fait une leçon fait leçon concernant les
subventions qu'il faut attendre et qu'on
ne les a pas tout de suite de suivre
l'exemple vivant je sais très bien
comment ça se passe d'ailleurs lui-même
il m'a envoyé on arrêtait de subventions
de plus au mois de juillet pour une
programmation 2010 9 essais vous ça que
je lui dis que je n'ai pas besoin de
cette leçon concernant le fonctionnement
des subventions ça m'a pas empêché entre
présidents d'associations de partis avec
un groupe de personnes âgées de jeunes
aller visiter la guyane française sans
sa subvention
donc en matière de gestion et de
subventions je demande à monsieur perez
de de se regarder un peu en face et
d'éviter de faire trop de leçons
une fois je lui dis le 15 mars les
margotin nous donne la réponse
en ce qui me concerne et notre projet à
travers l'alliance nouvelle c3 dynamiser
ce centre-bourg vous même vous dites que
vous avez plaisir à venir sur le quai
d'ailleurs l'ancien maire du magot peut
en témoigner
j'ai toujours donné des exemples soit
sur cet espace à marigot eh bien nous
avons mis des opérations en place telles
que lyon bichot net ce qui a bien
fonctionné et d'ailleurs dans ma
proposition pour la prochaine mandature
jeudi remarque beauté pourquoi ne pas
virer de margaux b comme ça se fait dans
d'autres îles de la caraïbe maîtres de
l'animation mais l'animation c'est pas
tout c'est un ensemble
quand vous créer de l'animation c'est de
la créativité c'est de l'économie pour
les quelques restaurants que nous avons
à margaux le peu de commerces
nous sommes une petite commune
maintenant la fierté que j'ai jadis
entre parenthèses ses devoirs
les jeunes qui fonctionnait que nos
doigts puis un certain nombre de tant
d'années du moins bien on revienne ils
ont été formés parce que moi je ne fais
que ça dans l'équipe que j'ai avant 2014
nous avons géré sur l'emploi le lot
alors pour développer l'emploi
votre proposition les propositions des
vins mutuel en passe et pas uniquement
la commune qui va créer des emplois
c'est mettre en place un cadre bien
entendu pour permettre et c'est vrai on
dit que nous sommes une petite commune
que des entreprises aient envie qu'ils
sentent cette attractivité du territoire
ce qui se passe à marigot et c'est pour
ça que je me bats c'est comme monsieur
perez a détruit cette chose cette fierté
ma routine
c'est vrai que le cadre de la vie d'emma
gottéron changer parce que monsieur
personne n'a pas contribué à cela et
c'est ce qu'ils avaient placé en lui
cette envie en tant qu'entrepreneur
soi-disant de voir le margot rayonner
moi je dis pour créer de l'emploi il
faut mettre en place les conditions
normales faut que les entreprises
viennent nous avons un espace c'est à la
pointe j'en crois que c'est cette zone
qui pourra nous permettre d'accueillir
quelques entreprises les gens qui
violent qui voulait comme les jeunes
margotin qui porte et qui font des
études venu justement je donne les temps
de parole monsieur gros désir ces
minutes 49 monsieur bré n'a six minutes
trente et une sans compter est-ce alors
29 39 30 monsieur lavenère quatre
minutes 05
donc c'est vous qui est en déficit et
monsieur peraste cinq minutes 34 c'est à
vous monsieur peraste weed man des
solutions pour l'emploi et
l'attractivité du marigot
tout à fait alors je voudrais dire
concernant cet aspect la ville du
marigot l'a accueilli et quand même plus
de 50 emplois à un rythme deux jeunes
tant au niveau de l'espace vert qu'au
niveau du fleurissement et aussi au
niveau de désenclavement puisque nous
faisons aussi des travaux en régie faut
savoir que pendant vingt ans il y a eu
une gestion où personne ne peut dire que
y compris les deux candidats monsieur
lavenère et monsieur désir qui se sont
inquiétés du patrimoine communal
c'est à dire que quand on veut
développer une commune tout chef
d'entreprise lance des perspectives sous
les 15 20 années à venir
ça n'a pas été le cas puisque nous
n'avons que 80 mille mètres carrés de
terrain que la ville dispose et c'était
80 mille mètres carrés acquis par michel
renard voyez un peu que c'est très vieux
aujourd'hui c'est ce dont dispose la
ville du marigot vous développer ses
projets et bien quand même même si c'est
petit c'est très peu j'ai pu lancer
l'opération la zone d'activité
économique et que l'on ait ce qu'ils
n'ont pas assez d'information dommage
mais que l'on n'arrivait à cap nord
puisque vous n'êtes pas sans savoir
qu'avec la loi d'autres depuis 2010 est
la compétence de construction de
réalisation de zones d'activités
économiques
c'est la compétence de cap nord même si
moi mr dumas hugo je voulais réaliser là
une zone d'aménagement économique je ne
peux pas puisque la compétence est
retirée au maire elle est donnée à la
communauté d'agglo ne se lavent dans le
xi très bien puisque il a eu l'occasion
de diriger
donc j'ai confié cette mission depuis
trois ans à cap nord qui est en train de
ressentir ce projet mais donnons le
temps au temps mais soyons efficaces et
puis donnant des perspectives car dans
cette zone il est prévu la réalisation
d'un centre commercial
il est prévu la réalisation de bureaux
et d'ateliers pour les toutes petites
entreprises du marigot
il est prévu un centre d'accueil pour
grand handicap en fait toute une série
de choses que nos amis donc je considère
encore que les candidats sont des amis
que nous à parce qu'ils sont abonnés
après le 15 mars à travailler avec moi
donc nos amis et bien qu'il se dise
simplement patience je ne suis qu'à ma
première mandature il y en a qui ont
fait 3 aujourd'hui j'entends même doit
être sa tétine sur une saison qui
clamaient les virage entendu même l'un
durs font pas renouvelé mais nous on ne
peut pas dire se quitter mais c'est à
vous
rappelons solution roland doit notamment
de la jeunesse au marigot la politique
de l'emploi c'est une compétence d'état
première chose deuxième chose ce qu'il
faut faire c'est rapprocher les services
de l'état vers les communes
il faut d'abord une élue chargée de
l'insertion faire en sorte justement que
c'était lui la com l'avons fait pendant
mes deux mandatures et nous l'avons fait
et comme ça on fait des recrutements
nous assurions pelé line pleinement la
formation des personnes en question de
façon à ce que les personnes un diplôme
qualifiant je suis pas sûr
qu'aujourd'hui ça soit le cas
c'est pas le cas donc par conséquent un
juge maintenant la ville peu de temps en
temps quand il ya un chantier important
de la commune exigé que la clause
sociale soit appliquée de façon ce qui
est des recrutements de la commune que
je sache il ya un chantier de près de
800000 euros ça dépend du moment où 10
le chiffre ça peut être puissant vous
êtes plus à 3 260 milles ça dépend du
joug de leur jeu pour sous-entendez quoi
gérer ces chantiers sûreté de l'église
qui lui fait mal
toujours il n'ya pas il n'y a pas un mal
gotein ayant travaillé sur ce chantier
là ya pas un seul
je rappelle que quand j'ai fait la place
de l'église avec les collèges il ya eu
trois maris goûter a été recruté
ça aussi c'est la d ouverture d'emploi
pour les gens du marigot
mais monsieur père à sa fille s'occupe
pas d'eux sans lui
tadic aujourd'hui c'est bien pour ça que
je suis candidat pour remettre le malgré
un endroit parce que vous lui est à
l'envers on fait des choses vous ne sait
pas on est un petit peu dans le bocage
le brocante âge et ça c'est très grave
et moi je dis qu'aujourd'hui il faut et
je le répète je sais que ça lui fait mal
que l'église soit réparée quelle console
belle aurait parlé mais je reste
quelques salves elle n'était pas dans
votre projet désolé
les textes disent les délibérations
c'est conseil municipal de nice j'ai mon
programme la de 2014 et j'ai la
réparation de l'église à la page c'était
prévu en même temps que moi en 2014
c'est assez bien de vos objets c'est
vrai je voulais trouver c'est pas dans
votre catalogue de programmes alors nous
exprimer ses bad dans votre catalogue de
programmes mieux vaut garder le c'est
pas dans votre catalogue de programmes
l'église ne racontez pas d'histoire et
c'est fait vous avez des on l'a fait
c'est tant mieux
dieu merci c'est tant mieux les mâles
gauteng largement contribuer à la
réparation
pas du tout vous vous trompez encore
trompé c'est parti je vais le dire le
super âge tout à l'heure vous avez la
parole
l'aventuré et des travaux réalisés par
la mairie de super a laissé parler
monsieur la vierge avait exposé ma
parole je n'ai pas dîné c'est pas le
confondre les gens dans vos affaires
comme d'habitude d'ailleurs fait encore
quand j'ai dit que les habitants
participent au travail c'est ce qu'à
vous de l'année alors je dis ont
contribué parce qu'on a demandé à mme
antivj mulliez participer mais bien sûr
mais sinon tribu c'est pas la différence
vous savez très bien alors avant de
passer à la deuxième thématique je vous
donne vos nouveaux temps de parole
monsieur gros désir 6,49 monsieur bredas
9 30
monsieur lavenère 6,57 et monsieur
peraste disent maintenant on va laisser
continuer donc monsieur l'avenir
rapidement sur les problèmes d'emploi
avant de passer donc à la thématique de
passe que vous êtes en retard vous avez
3 4 de retard mais vivent là dessus
c'est très simple il faut pas bouger dit
aux gens valorisant pas ça n'est pas
vrai on disait des choses aux gens c'est
des mensonges
il faut être pragmatique il faut mettre
en place des plans d'organisation de
façon à ce que le moment venu en plus
intégrer les gens nous fait à mesure
assuré n'est ce pas la promotion déjà
des agences sont en place oui mais on
vous parlait d'argent municipaux moi je
vous parle simplement de faire venir au
marigot
une agence qui permet de la commune est
le premier employeur de la ville une
petite commune 3000 et 3200 habitants
maintenant mais il n'y a pas
d'infrastructures mais nous nous
évoquions simplement le fait de faire un
salon de l'emploi au marigot
mais n'est-ce pas à l'époque ce qui la
reprise tant mieux que la mission locale
et en place sous la commune
n'est ce pas la politique qui nous reste
trente minutes de débat il nous avons
encore deux thématiques abordées alors
messieurs il y a 6 ans vous étiez tous
candidats
j'étais tous candidats qu'est ce qui
vous motive au marigot
est ce que il y a un trésor caché à la
mairie monsieur daniel braud désir oui
il n'ya pas y'a pas de quoi casser ça on
l'aurait déjà trouvé où la parité du
genre de siège
ils l'ont aidé à trouver mais c'est un
petit peu trop facile que monsieur
terrasse et monsieur l'avenir seront
voix et la balle la balle ainsi monsieur
à venir est resté 19 à la commune et
j'avais dit à monsieur l'avenir il se
rappelle souvent quand il a fini sa
première mandature
je lui avais dit qu'il avait raté sa
poignée mandature et le fait de rater sa
peau les mandatures on lui a donné cinq
six sept mandature il n'aurait jamais
réussi d'autres parce que la première
mandature s'est glissé très important et
je dis la même chose amusé perez quand
on a raté sa première mandature on peut
toujours on peut avoir cinq six sont peu
demandées 30e' que voilà il me faut un
deuxième etc
non c'est ce que c'est mal bâti c'est
mal parti et c'est le problème des
problèmes que nous avons et je demande
aux uns et aux autres de ne pas se
battre sous l'église parce qu'il ya
énormément de choses à dire sous ces
travaux d'église et que et j'aurais aimé
jouer mais vraiment par par
condescendance pour la population de ne
pas se battre que ce sous l'église
chacun c'est de faire ce qu'on essaie de
faire c'est ce qu'il pouvait en ce
moment nous avons notre église qu'une
équipe de services de sécurité deux
départements la quantité que c'est pas
aux normes
donc chacun s'est de fait ce qu'il
pouvait c'est pas ça veut pas
aujourd'hui qu'on fait des travaux sur
les églises de gros travaux sur cette
église
chaque municipalité depuis x temps
chacun afin petit un peu dessus donc
j'aimerais qu'on a on ne se base pas là
dessus qu'on ne pense pas que les
catholiques sont des idiots et parce que
l'aide de l'église et intérêts par un
ils vont voter pour quelqu'un ans ils
ont quand même beaucoup d'autres choses
en tête beaucoup de réflexion à faire à
commencer par moi même qui suis un peu
catholiques pratiquants et donc je dis
que le problème du marigot c'est pas il
est qu'il y un trésor le problème du
marigot ce que nous avons eu depuis 95
nous avons eu des demandes qui ne se
sont pas occupés de la commune qui se
pensent pas occupé de la population qui
ne sont pas intéressés à cette
population et c'est ce qui est grave
c'est que la population demande quand on
nettoie le problème d'image c'est
surtout ça ils ont l'impression de ne
pas être représentés et que bon nous on
en arrive avec la participation de la
démocratie participative travailler avec
la population est directement contact
avec la population
travailler avec la population c'est ce
problème la ville qui se passe au maroc
on ne se bat pas pour chercher quelque
chose moi b seulement je me bats pour
être au service des marigots d'un alors
monsieur brian et monsieur peraste il ne
vous reste pas beaucoup de temps
donc s'il vous plaît si vous pouvez
pardonnez moi l'expression évacuer cette
question rapidement je la reprends ce
qui est un trésor caché au marigot
monsieur a hélas il n'y a pas de trésor
caché à la mairie ni au marigot
ça pourrait être le sujet d'une
attraction pour le mage vous trouvez le
trouver l'occasion du ragot je pense que
les mammouths et vont peut-être trouver
ce trésor au soir du 15 mars
on ne sait jamais on sans prétention
aucune bien entendu
maintenant pour nous ce qui concerne les
élections de 2014
nous sommes revenus en 2020 voire
simplement et très démocratiquement je
répète tout le temps
les mâles gauthey se sont dits en 2014
que c'était pas encore notre tour nous
avons accepté cela maintenant ils nous
ont positionné comme dans un champion
dans un championnat
vous sortez troisième on attend de la
prochaine saison quand vous puissiez
faire mieux
et puis gagner voilà donc c'est tout à
fait logique notre dimanche deux
candidats mais ses pairs est oui
j'appuie la déclaration et la thèse
adverse
tous nous avons le droit d'être candidat
mais il ya quand même quelque chose qui
me faut foisonnent dans la déclaration
de monsieur désir parce qu'il a parlé de
monsieur ange lavenaire qui avait raté
ma nature et qu' il valait raté tous y
compris patrie das puisqu'il l'a fait
quand même 13 ans parce qu'on a l'air
d'oublier ça très sain avec ange
lavenaire et puis jeudi et que lui-même
daniel hugo désire lui aussi il est
comptable de cette mandature de
l'inconnu que c'était pas réussi jeudi
qu'il est comptable de cet échec si
échec il y a jusqu'à 42 oui avec ma
complicité ou encore je dirais mat avec
nous aoun j j lo nos impôts donc je
pense que c'est vous on a le doigt tous
d'être candidat on a le doigt tous de
chercher ce trésor du mali où le trésor
et bien il y est puisque le maillot a
été une commune qui a accueilli beaucoup
d'amérindiens le mag est une commune où
il ya beaucoup d'artistes parler de
monsieur victor année celle de monsieur
timothée enfin y'en a plein de naples un
peu jeune mona et cetera je crois que
c'est là le trésor et nous maintenant
élus nous devrions essayer de faire 2 1
de faire émerger ces trésors ces
personnalités et c'est ce que je fais en
ce moment puisque avec monsieur victor
anicette nous faisons un gros travail
sur la point donc ce trésor nous l'avons
et bien à toulon nous nous en jeu
l'avenir patrick bidasses daniel vous
désirez vous ressemble et comme la
spéculation a confié déjà une mandature
à joseph terrasses fermées sur l'une est
mère ce monsieur perez alors monsieur
l'avenir il est bien que je ne vous
posez pas la même question vous avez 73
a débattu michel foucault n'a été prise
à ce jour
la mairie j'imagine oui c'est un jeune
reporter à l'époque
vous avez été mais vous avez été
conseiller général vous avez participé à
la création de quatre noms pourquoi
est-ce que vous avez aujourd'hui besoin
de revenir chez moi
1 le code électoral prévoit un âge
minimum un animal s'il s'agit pas de ça
non permettez que je développe pouvez
aller vous deuxièmement il ne prévoit
pas non plus un nombre de mandature
maximum n'a pas de limites meilleur
coach qui est très important le code
moral dont on ne parle pas mais qu'on
soit du 30 mars
j'ai perdu les élections j'ai eu la
divine lumière de rester assis et je
conseille d'y installer le nouveau
conseil municipal procéder à l'élection
du maire parce que je n'étais pas obligé
lycée m'a parlé pas obligé je suis resté
installé le bringuebal procéder à
l'élection du maire je suis le doyen du
conseil
il fait participer un site de conseils
municipaux et j'ai vu un fonctionnement
j'ai vu comment ça se passe et ça ne
répondait pas aux attentes des
maillotins parce que quand on vieillit
là on veut pas pour se servir mon vient
pour servir dans avec les amis qui m'ont
sollicité d'ailleurs je souhaite être
que d'autres vieilles peut-être que si
monsieur patrick bride as était resté à
l'époque
depuis 2008 on peut citer lui celle là
maintenant candidat ma place vous
l'auriez vous l'auriez supporter je n'ai
aucun problème par rapport à ça
si c'était lui qui te lever une
déclaration non mais ça j'ai pas voulu
le dire mais c'est une affaire d'hommes
et onenote et du respect de l'homme et
de l'homme je le dis c'est bien c'est
pourquoi chacun puisse comprendre que
l'audio a aujourd'hui ils doivent les
payer
d'une certaine façon vous parlez qui va
lui vous venez de ratisser oui après
vous donner
mais non mais une histoire meinau mais
il faut voir ce que j'ai dit je dis oui
pas c'était une erreur de nous avoir
laissé à l'époque c'est clair point bas
en 2008 en 2008 sérieux ça va je suis
l'ancien maire excusé
maintenant là aujourd'hui celle à venir
alors j'aimerais l'amener à l'avenir
c'est l'avenir monsieur l'avenir
maintenant je ne sais pas si je vais pas
pour t'emmerder mais quand monsieur
joseph père reste à gérer la commune
tels qu ils la font un bâtiment
administratif qui avait des locataires
les a chassés on disait qu'ils paient
pas leur loyer
ce qui était faux ou peut-être que la
leaf rdc par annexe de la mairie
le bâtiment tout simplement oui quand on
voit le parcours santé
tout a foutu le camp papeete mon
expression quand on voit tout ce qui
était la salle polyvalente qui devait
être une association ça aussi c'est
fermé quand on voit les associations
n'ont pas touché des subventions 2019
on annonce 3600 lui rien n'est payé on
me dit à madrid et financière il ya de
grosses difficultés financières
et là où vivait nous disions dans mon
groupe
comme je vous ai ferrasse il faut
arrêter le massacre il faut arrêter cela
mettant les électeurs auront dable de
leurs réseaux de soin qu'ils devront en
tout cas je suis déterminé parce que le
code moral ne pose à a dit non non non
et non il ne reste que vingt minutes
alors attendez 20 minutes de débat on
encore une thématique
alors justement que pensez vous
messieurs les candidats autres que
monsieur lavenère de son retour on
commence avec vous monsieur gros désir
est là vous pourrez ensuite vous
exprimer monsieur bredas de non
seulement leur tour leur tour non la
candidature de
lumières ne me pose aucun problème parce
que ça ne pose aucun problème au code
électoral
donc du coup moi ça me pose aucun
problème lit s'il sait qu'il a la santé
ciss il a la force et s'il a envie de
faire quelque chose il a tout à fait le
droit et que moi je me suis et jamais
posé cette question là particulier ça ne
me gêne absolument pas comme je vais
mieux
l'abonné soit candidat par contre c'est
ce qui me gêne sim c'est que le le ses
mandatures n'ont pas été des réussites
pour lamah pour le marigot
c'est ça qui me gêne c'est quand même un
certain moment doit se dire mais au fait
j'ai pas réussi à impulser quelque chose
de positif dans la commune pourquoi je
revis pourquoi je serais plus à même à
le faire maintenant
il pense qu'il va pouvoir le faire bon
tant mieux pour lui mais c'est trois
mandatures ont été des échecs pour la
commune monsieur bré concernant leur
retour de monsieur dernière c'est la
démocratie qui l'imposent fait quoi bon
lui semble pas quand je veux appeler
deux trois choses parce qu'il faut pas
vouloir falsifier l'histoire en 2008
quand j'ai laissé l'équipe de monsieur
l'avenir ancien maire je ne suis pas
parti comme ça je suis allé jusqu'au
bout de ma mandature j'ai dit à monsieur
l'ancien maire que je ne souhaitais pas
me représenter parce que je n'étais pas
à ma place et qui gère une imposition
demandeurs se sont ré ne correspondait
pas venir c'est tout maintenant faut pas
qu'il dise qu'il attendait que 2020
c'est ce que mon ton puisqu'en 2011
je suis venu face monsieur p gasquet
avait fait un très bon score survenu au
2e tour pour les cantonales pour sauver
monsieur l'ancien maire du naufrage
donc j'ai toujours été conscient et dans
ma démarche je n'ai jamais trahi
j'ai toujours respecté ma parole et les
gens margot vous le diront patrick benes
c'est ça la parole donnée je n'ai jamais
trahi
donc maintenant comme seul avenir trouve
comme excuse que ça soit moins que du
reste et je les vues en 2019
aussi pour lui demander son soutien il
m'a bien oui où il prépare toi mêlée
face à moi
maintenant ce n'est plus les les le nom
le moment est déjà venue de marc godin
vont faire le choix maintenant j'ai dit
à monsieur l'avenue aussi de glace vous
avez battu monsieur weiner de feu renard
michel renard de 24 voix monsieur il
n'est jamais loin
nous voyons tous pleuré devant la
population vous répéter à chaque fois 84
voix mais vous avez perdu
moi il m'a manqué c'est sans voix donc
le mérite et la farine oui je devrais
parler de quoi je ne sais pas simplement
le retour de monsieur l'avenir je crois
que c'est son doigt la loi le lui permet
maintenant c'est à lui de savoir qu'au
lendemain du 15 mars
eh bien il faudrait que définitivement
ils comprennent quel que soit le code
électoral puisque ça voudra dire que le
peuple une nouvelle fois vous a dit
monsieur ange lavenaire rester dans
votre coin vous avez donné vous avez
beaucoup donné et on vous remercie
alors qu'ici nous allons mettre à parler
d'aménagement du territoire avance
encore me demandent de donner de donner
à nos candidats leur temps de parole
monsieur gros désir 10,33 monsieur
bredas 11,54 monsieur lavenère on se dit
c'est monsieur peyras non non monsieur
lavenère 10 47 et monsieur peyras 13 et
des poussières je ne me relis plus alors
on va donc et vous évoqué l'aménagement
du territoire avec un port de pêche
christine alors le port de pêche du
marigot et de fait ou non on a compris
un port intercommunale nous avons
entendu un donc dans la commune des
personnes veulent un stade où des
infrastructures culturelles
est-ce que vous candidat être prêt à
faire comprendre à vos électeurs qu à
cause de la baisse de la population
il serait difficilement envisageable de
construire un stade juste pour la
commune on commence avec vous monsieur
gros désir
oui et je voudrais pas tout de suite que
oui et vous avez donné de chiffres de la
bri stade
pas question d'être la communalité non
il faut que c'est un stade de vase on
est comme tout le monde avait pensé que
de celle de sept mérités un stade
intercommunal
bon c'est pas le cas le il faut
consulter parce que ça ne s'est pas
seulement juste on m'a fait des matches
de foot dessus c'est un endroit où il ya
un vivre ensemble on peut faire d'autres
manifestations les gens peut se
retrouver
grandes personnes et surtout il ya
beaucoup d'adultes beaucoup de
brigandage qu'on en a beaucoup qui
allait marcher faire la petite marche
sous le stade parce que c'est tout plat
cela permettait de sortir il faut
absolument installer par pas simplement
une heure de jeu parce que eux deux il y
en a et puis ce que ce qu'on appelle une
aire de jeu quelle dimension que ça n'a
pas de sens il faut faire un stade pour
que les jeunes aux jeunes qui en ce
moment il faut bien réfléchir à ce
moment notre jeune anna des u11 u12 u13
des u 15 ii sont des enfants aujourd'hui
ils ont besoin d'un ils font le
championnat il se lève à 4 heures du
matin pour pouvoir aller avons eu lieu
pour faire le match aller est encore la
semaine d'après pour faire le match
retour ou alors à saint joseph
ce qui fait les gens ne sont pas motivés
ils peuvent pas être motivé comme ça
c'est le stade est indispensable le
terrain de handball sans que plus
indispensables parce que tu nous donnes
balle quand même une commune qui n'a pas
intérêt d'un bal c'est désastreux
et puis la mise aux normes du gnl du
gymnase et sur des choses indispensables
mais je dis aussi que ceux d'autres
cases et pourtant pour l'éducation ce
sont nos écoles alors l'inter des
ménages bridée à ce qu'est ce qu'il est
possible de faire qu'est-ce qui est pas
possible de faire moi écouter on connaît
bien le rôle de l'intercommunalité
moi je suis pour l'intercommunalité que
j'avais voulu quelque chose c'est que on
ne pense pas aux transports à margaux
pour l'instant nous avons une équipe on
a des difficultés
d'ailleurs les véritables fossoyeurs du
sport du football à margaux ce sont ces
messieurs monsieur peyras et monsieur
goût désir en particulier et j'avoue et
bien entendu parce que je vous rappelle
que celle de vos illustres compagnons
qui a quand même laissé une tête de plus
de 10000 euros
la jsm et jusqu'à là aujourd'hui
la gsm 900 soit vous étiez à la réunion
et moi je vous avais l'un des élus qui
était président de la jsm je vous dis
2 si vous êtes les fossoyeurs de quel
est le gars là j'ai un agent si vous
permettez monsieur vos désirs si vous
permet avec la russie m vous avez
maintenant je dis toujours la vérité
vaincra je voulais
une chose si l'angola gsm avait ce qu'on
peut convenir d'appeler le bal de la
jsmc ce qui permettait à la gsl
d'engranger un peu de sous et de prévoir
leur messie monsieur l'ancien maire a
été président de la jsm je ne raconte
pas d'histoires c'est la réalité c'est
vous même qui avait plongé la gsm et moi
je prends non vous êtes à voter non si
nous sommes choisis
nous allons faire les frottements
particulier pour remettre la jsm soleil
je vais donner une information marie
goûter que nous écoutent la jsm a eu un
match sauf par forfait la semaine
dernière aujourd'hui j'ai reçu le
message ils sont en train de prier pour
que les anciens de la gsm ou reviennent
même s'il ne s'entraîne pas simplement
pour avoir la feuille de match vous
connaissez saison passée nombreux mais
son passé mais c'est parce que c'est ce
qu'on a détruit avec vous la fierté
marigot tine et on va la retrouver à
travers cette envie à leur donner en
gage est simple école de quoi être agile
et sportivement goodwin c'est sur cela
que l'expérience et sur langon bartik
monsieur pigasse a gagné d'après ce qui
se dit à margaux parce que il était prêt
à tout fait aux boules mais monsieur
vous désirez deux fois plus condamnable
parce que il a accompagné monsieur perez
dans cette démarche qui a floué la gsl
j'ai mon fils qui a joué à la jsm
je suis au match le temps de donner
votre piscine éthique parce que c'est
vous qui avez le temps très longue le
temps d'un de nos stades je dis qu'il
faut développer le transport et on était
en communalité voir comment coryez sur
ce stade parce que nous n'avons pas le
financement du système
et contrairement aux belles paroles et
promesses de monsieur p as
j'attends de voir la traduction à
margaux de ce budget monsieur par sfr
est ben je vais dire très simplement que
ça y est pour l'heure ce stade nous
avons les documents
nous savons déjà c'est à dire monsieur
quand vous dites ça y est pour l'instant
nous avons les deux experts nous avons
déjà le lieu d'implantation
c'est à l'appoint tout le monde le sait
je crois que ce soit la fête patronale
de dominantes que ce soit la fête du
goût du marigot
nous avons exposé à la population nous
avons eu des conférences des réunions de
consultation de la population à ce
niveau public
donc on ne peut pas le nier le stade
sera désormais donc à la pointe puisque
le maire du malg son équipe municipale
ont essayé de réparer mais impossible
parce que le sol ne permet plus nous
avons même commencé à jouer là-dessus et
il lui suffit de trois jours de pluie ou
qu'il y ait ni l'adresse de 40 cm bon
donc il faut que le maire comprennent de
façon définitive qu'on ait cap ce
plateau qui restera un plateau de vie le
meilleur pour l'équipe
joseph erard et nous voyons encore il
sera encore le maire de la prochaine
mandature
j'ai confiance à la population jeune a
dit comme je le pensais comme je le vis
donc il faut savoir donc le stade sera
la roue mais enfin il n'y a pas que le
stade où le marigot
il y a des perspectives de développement
donc je demande à tout un chacun y
compris la population d'être attentif à
ce que nous allons proposer et et je
leur demande d'être est simplement de
permettre que l'équipe que je mène
puisse continuer encore une mandature
mais l avenir oui alors le stade je
l'avais dit en 2014 ça a été l'objet de
mon et chef comprendre un stade du crua
tu t'es où on fait le stade dans les six
mois en hausse au stade 6 ans ont passé
les gens voient bien et soupe à saper
entre êtes vous à payer 2 pc pays 3
aujourd'hui les buts
et comme nous ne permettent pas n'est ce
pas ce type de réalisation sont des
réalisations qui vont dans le cadre
communautaire d'ailleurs déplaise aux
yeux aux autres à 7 mario on voit bien
la situation du stade de 7,9 en plus des
chocs ou qui sont arrivés par des
événements n'est ce pas naturel donc
aujourd'hui il faut être réaliste et des
auvents la vérité le dis qu'il faut pas
croire que les communes peuvent tout
faire ça n'est pas possible ça n'est
plus possible et je rappelle notamment
que les dotations d'état baissent de
façon significative non plus leur poids
demain il ya un point d'interrogation
sur l'eau de mer et les communes avec la
perte d'habitants évidemment ça pose des
problèmes de pet de problèmes de
démographie de démographie
aujourd'hui la réflexion c'est à dire on
doit mettre un chapeau équipements
sportifs
il faut voir quel type d'équipement on
le sait où et margot il n'y a pas 100
millions à marigot
s'agissant justement de cette amende
d'aménagement du territoire
le plu le plan local d'urbanisme a été
votée à mon époque il est en révision en
ce moment oui mais dans la vision il ya
dix ans donc parce que c'est normal nous
allons réparer bien des choses mais
j'espère que c'est fait pour ça les
révisions va se réparer bien les jeux
vous rasant de plaintes enregistrées par
la populace je vous réponds je vous
rappelle que le plu a été la bonne à un
moment où il y avait six tombes de
textes nationaux qui n'était pas sorti
il faut l'adapter la pousse enfin je
vais m'adapter
oui ne vous en faites pas non par weight
la population donc par conséquent là
dessus là tu as fait a pas à discuter
site réglementaire 2-2 fait la religion
il faut que la face bon maintenant
aujourd'hui je dis aux gens il faut
absolument que la population comprenne
que des trois domaines sur lesquels la
commune peut intervenir c'est sous les
personnes âgées les écoles également la
partie sportive parce qu'il ya lieu de
faire quelque chose alors une minute
pour jouir question avec didier de ce
pack wii alors y minutes à pour cette
question avant les conclusions on l'a
dit les marins pêcheurs et les
restaurateurs ont été frappés de plein
fouet par l'invasion des algues sargasse
avec comme conséquence un fort
ralentissement de l'activité économique
la ville du marigot à dépenser 170000
euros en 2018 pour la lutte contre les
serres grâce en achetant notamment le
truc sorte un engin amphibie pour le
fauchage et le ramassage des halles
alors d'après vous candidat était ce la
bonne solution
monsieur gros désir toujours mieux
passer leur faudrait une correction le
truc sort pour le moment n'a pas coûté 5
centimes à la ville du marin ces gens
vous induisent en erreur depuis quelques
panneaux nos sondés et bien non le truc
sort on n'a pas nous parlons du projet
de brouillard voilà avec la ville de
raconter seulement dix mille euros sur
100000 euros
donc je ne vois que tu es mis en place
depuis aujourd'hui la taille du marigot
n'a pas payé 500 je le loue à droite les
vous le souhaitez attendez je me suis
dédié au plaisir je suis en double mais
attendait dans la voiture et clément
franchement je ne pensais pas qu'on dise
réduit facile à avaux la défense qui n'a
rien fait encore mais oui mais pas assez
bien pour ça qu'il faut faire très
attention quand il parle c'est bien sûr
alors à socrate 6 rue d'épinal désir
s'il vous plaît à saint beauzire pour
arina pays du tout et c'est bien pour sa
recette piège
il faut bien sûr qu'il dit ou bien
écouter ce qui s'est déjà clôturé le
premier débat on en a des débats
président on en a parlé
je crois que ça a été ça a été ça a été
clair mais je vais je vais quand même je
combine quand même revenir à au pouce et
les pauvres de
2 ne se bride à ce qu'ils sont c'est
vrai que un tantinet désespérant voilà
quelqu'un qui a passé 13 ans en tant que
adjoint au maire à la municipalité dont
qui a touché près de 80000 euros et qui
a laissé les civils a le le la commune
dans un état désastreux et qui viennent
me donner une leçon à moi qui est en
fait pour les associations de peyras
valeur peut le confirmer et me donner me
donner des leçons à moi sur la vie
associative et me dire que même pgg de
soutiens quelqu'un qui avait dix mille
euros de déficit et c'est alors que j'ai
moi même jour puis toutes les la gestion
de la jsm mettre cette association à
flots et que l'année dernière lorsque
l'association s'apprêtait à disparaître
alors que je n'étais plus élu c'est à
moi qu'ils ont fait appel pour pouvoir
essayer de monter un conseil
d'administration pour que l'association
existe d une association qui a 49 ans
qui aura 50 ans cette année et que ça me
désespère est de cette association
disparaissent la veille de ses 50 ans
alors à part moi que vous avez donner de
leçons là-dessus et les 80000 euros delà
de l'âme et de la collectivité que vous
avez puis et que vous n'avez peut-être
pas que vous allez faire vous avez fait
avec moi je sais où sont passés les
indemnités que je recevais parce que moi
je les ai investi dans la vie publique
dans la vie associative dans la vie
auprès auprès de certaines personnes
moi je les ai investi g parce que mon
temps je donne mon temps je sers la
population on ne venait pas donner de
leçons de gens vous avez vous avez
raison vous avez tout dit et cetera les
treize ans que vous avez passé à
à la commune ne sont pas 13 ans a effacé
comme ça s'il vous plaît mais je me suis
remise et messieurs vous disiez vous
désirez ce que désire simplement vous
parlez de salaire d'un autre des bâches
et enfin de quoi vous parlez vous avez
vous choisi de ne pas répondre à la
question posée mais ça y est vous avez
choisi de ne pas répondre à la question
posée sur le traitement des zags pour
répondre à monsieur qu'au désir mais bon
c'est pas très facile pour répondre à
monsieur
en revanche je suis monsieur oui mais en
revanche l'histoire d'anciens des
bandages a parlé je sais pas de quoi
vous parlez
donc monsieur l'ena s'il vous plaît et
avoue un sujet très important rigaux
monsieur vous disiez le monsieur s'il
vous reste un peu de temps ils veulent
levac un problème qui nous coûtent très
cher et ont tous quatre minutes avant
l'afrique a fait un truc se regarder
derrière la mairie qui a coûté dix mille
cent mille euros et jusqu'à maintenant
monsieur ps maire monsieur goudé ils
sont complices n'avait pas nous donner
nous citoyens my boutin compte
contribuable le montant qu'ils ont
dépensé plus merci merci beaucoup
mercredi merci monsieur pédestre se perd
rapidement très clair gestion des alpes
au marigot le document il est là ça peut
faire sourire on peut dire ce qu'on veut
le dtr est à 55 jours le public
rapidement des atr et à 55% donc 55000
euros de l'état
la ctm 20 pour cent vingt mille euros
cap nord 15 bon sens quinze mille euros
la commune de marigot 10 pour cent dix
mille euros
donc quand on dit que nous avons acheté
un trousseau et que nous avons dépensé
100 mille euros c'est induit la
population en erreur
deuxièmement la participation de la
commune devait être de 10000 euros et je
viens de donner une information très
importante où j'ai dit il était question
de plans d'urgence
c'est à dire que les services de la rs
les services de l'état et la
collectivité cap nau et la ctm voulait
être le même registre il
diatement et nous avons donc fait un
dossier parce que cet appareil semblait
être l'appareil approprié parce que
n'oubliez pas qu'il est rappelé que la
vie économique des marins pêcheurs dont
il fallait que le mirage il était
question de santé et j'ai terminé en
disant qu' heureusement qu'il y ait ce
truc sort parce que cela éviter des
morts au mal monsieur rapidement mais
cela veut dire que ça fait tout ça je
valais l'occasion monsieur pure est
heureux tu as menti à la population du
monde à l'ordre
alors maintenant on va passer aux mon
client est là qu on va passer aux
conclusions tirées pendant que vous
sachiez où vous en êtes apte à l'heure
actuelle quant au désir monsieur gros
désir 14 30 monsieur bredas 14,55
monsieur peraste 16 07
monsieur lavenère 14 06 alors lite le
les conclusions monsieur gros désir
monsieur peraste monsieur brida spéciale
à venir on y va 2000 en 2001 10 signaler
à la population des chaînes de monsieur
l'avenir qui demandait une nouvelle
mandature
parce qu'il disait être en stage je lui
avais dit que lorsqu'on échoue après six
ans on ne rattrape jamais le temps perdu
et il ne l'a pas rattrapé malgré la
pression de la population le margot a
périclité
c'est le même constat pour monsieur
perez qui a pour seule raison de
continuer qu'il n'a pas vu passer des
six années là non plus on ne ratera pas
le temps perdu mais sachant qu'on peut
arrêter de perdre son temps ensemble
bâtissons notre avenir invite les
margotin à ne pas commettre que la même
erreur de mettre en place des hommes qui
ne sont pas prêts à se mettre à son
service
mais qui voudrait juste à s'ouvrir un
raid merci mais nous demandons à toutes
les bonnes volontés qui aiment le
marigot de nous rejoindre
bonne soirée et que dieu vous bénisse
monsieur père est bien je voudrais
simplement dire à mes amis du marigot et
à la population entière qu'ils m'ont
confié un mandat avec une équipe en
le 1014 je crois que nous n'avons pas
démérité c'est vrai nous n'avons
peut-être pas fait tout ce qu'il fallait
août est ce que la population attendait
dans la mesure aussi où nous
n'attendions pas les salgas amis du
marigot
donc tout ce que je demande c'est de
pouvoir poursuivre pour une mandature de
six ans qui sera la dernière aussi je
m'engage pour une mandature
eh bien nous permettre de pousser les
travaux que nous avons entamé
je vous remercie merci beaucoup alors
monsieur bredas alors je dis marketing
margotin c'est volontairement que j'ai
choisi la voie du coeur et de la raison
pour m'adresser à vous ce soir je n'ai
pas d'information de jouissent ni encore
d'avocat mais j'espère avoir plaidé la
cause du marigot qui se trouve dans un
état lamentable en 2014 rappelez-vous
nous étions déjà plus de 400 à fêter
dignement nos fiançailles après six ans
des changes quotidien leurs revenus pour
nous de célébrer cette belle union se
marier ici indispensable à la survie de
notre belle commune masterisation ne
l'est pas le temps de benjamin e-voting
et au marigot tine que vous avez compris
que monsieur peyras et monsieur vous
désirez ici ont la même politique et ne
font que vous mentiez hauts depuis un
certain nombre de temps qu'il faut
changer de politique et nous sommes là
pour ça et nous invitons au soir de cap
du 15 mars 2020 à nous rejoindre pour
passer à autre chose donner un autre a
dit margot au marigot et je vous dis
qu'il est possible de faire tout cela
mais simplement dégoûté margutti il faut
y croire
merci monsieur non c'est très simple moi
je reviens parce qu'il ya une demande
aujourd'hui on voit bien qu'à une
fracture entre population et également
les associations avec la mutualité
il faut recréer du lien et seul un homme
d'expérience de crédible et attentif à
la population qui vient pour servir et
non pour se servir
donc je vous invite donc avec l'équipe
que j'anime accompagné notamment de
camarades france michel qui aujourd'hui
est avec nous et il n'est pas là par
hasard
ce n'est pas le même contexte qu'en 2014
15 vous travaillez depuis six ans
ensemble depuis six mois pardon depuis
six mois ensemble depuis six mois de
façon oui mais c'est peut-être plus fort
peu qu'elle ait fait parler oui mais
c'est comme ça des parasites donc par
conséquent faire en sorte que cette
équipe là qui vous sera présenté le
moment venu à lui permettent n'est ce
pas de relever le marigot sortie n'est
ce pas n'est ce pas de la
décrédibilisation merci messieurs merci
aux candidats du marigot merci à vous
téléspectateurs et téléspectatrices de
votre fidélité on se retrouve mardi soir
mardi prochain ce sera un nouveau débat
avec d'autres candidats puisque nous
recevrons ceux du marin excellente
soirée à tous et à toutes ainsi qu'à
vous feront créateur c'est merci à
bientôt
[Musique]